we heard from the governor of washington
this week
talking about climate change as a
permanent emergency
so my question is how how does the news
media cover a permanent emergency
just treat it like your ratings bozo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so excited well well well well i hope
you enjoyed your fourth of july
i know cat did
he's fine i mean you know it's cat but
now the fourth as you know celebrates
our independence from some toothless
weirdos
it's quite an accomplishment to trounce
an empire so 250 years later
we can listen to this are you proud to
be an american
no i feel embarrassed to be an american
every day
i think a lot of things about this
country are really embarrassing
just like i mean racist history
colonization
even currently just what's going on with
politics and
the cops i'm not really in this climate
no like i'm a black person so obviously
i
experience a lot of uh you know there's
like oppression that comes with that
um not most of the time i think
sometimes it's just a little
embarrassing
i think that's a complicated question
for me i think i
i i think most of the time no
at least over like the past four years
um it's been tricky to
you know love to be an american half
seas on that
like partly because like i feel like
there's certain topics where
it's like very controversial but like i
don't know
i just think that our economy just cares
about money and not like ours like
they're humans like yeah in general i
mean oh my g
i mean like she said like 433 times
halvsies i can't wait till she enters
the real world
it takes my order at arby's
all right so all these lovely people are
embarrassed by america
but do they have any alternatives can
you name a better country than the
united states in your opinion
i'm not sure if i can
i don't think i can um i mean there's
probably
a really tiny european country that
is thriving ooh good question
europe europe's not a country
you're good
maybe the british are better off without
us i mean their food still sucks but at
least they like their country
and i know surveys like this are like
shooting really stupid fish in a tiny
tiny barrel
college is where good grades don't
matter as long as you get a hammer and
sickle tattoo on your butt
still there but hey they're just dumb
kids right we can forgive them
but what happens when patriotism is now
considered offensive
by our very own leaders this weekend
idiots from maxine waters to corey bush
slammed fourth of july is nothing more
than a celebration of racism
i could read you their tweets but why
here's this
gist from bush quote the freedom they
are
referring to is for white people which
raises a point
perhaps our politicians do such an awful
job
because they hate america do you ever
think about that and their incompetence
is their weapon think about how easy it
is to subvert a republic
get elected then rot it from within and
if anyone challenges you
well that's racist meanwhile national
geographic
marked the fourth by tweeting that smoke
from fireworks causes
disproportionate harm to communities of
color
so i hope you enjoyed that roman candle
you racist
but of course national geographic's
virtue signal comes after decades of
exploiting communities of color all over
the world
oh look at topless women in their
natural habitat remember that
when i was a young man i just assumed
every naked woman carried a basket of
food on their heads
and then and then there's the new
facebook feature that warns users when
they've been exposed to extremist
content
facebook asks if you know someone who's
becoming an extremist
which is why this morning i ratted out
every anchor at cnn
but actually you know i did ask myself
if i came across
anything that seems extreme and i
did but oddly it's from facebook's mark
zuckerberg himself
what the hell was that i mean really
what the hell was that have you seen
anything
as white as that in your life
only i mean if riding a hydrofoil
surfboard holding an oversized american
flag isn't a mark of extremist
privileged behavior
what is all that's missing is the red
hat a rifle rack and a plate of racist
apple pie
i mean this in this era where patriotism
is merely a dog whistle for hate
couldn't one argue that any form of
patriotism in an oppressive racist
society
is celebrating its past and therefore an
example of extremism
i believe that's msnbc's mission
statement i mean zuckerberg is certainly
not helping his own case here
as he encourages citizens to knock on
citizens and it's working
at my fourth of july cookout i caught my
brisket wearing a wire
that's the corny joke but thanks to
facebook it's no longer media and
government policing your
beliefs they're motivating the public to
do the dirty work for you
it's the new version of if you see
something say something the only
difference is that something is no
longer an
unintended an unattended suitcase at the
airport
it's your buddy getting a don't tread on
me tattoo the rise of cancer culture
isn't a mistake
it's bad on purpose the fear over losing
one's job over something you said that's
intended
so that fear self-polices your own words
you don't need a government to do it
when your fear
silences you and debate mysteriously
disappears when the world's largest
social media platform asks you to knock
on your neighbors it's not just you
they're asking but your neighbors too
but at least real narcs point out people
who actually broke the law
so what if someone reports you according
to facebook you'll never know your
accusers
how stassy is that big brother eases you
into becoming their informant by
reminding you that quote others
in your situation have received
confidential support end quote
it's a high-tech self-made witness
protection plan
only when you rat somebody out you don't
have to change your name
grow a beard and move to scranton like
joe devito did
you can think without repercussions
quote take action now to protect
yourself and others facebook
says let facebook be the bad guy they're
protected not you
i remember when we were young we were
supposed to fight big brother not hold
hands with him
i wonder what the angry white male
[Music]
thinks
me well i guess i spent the holiday
feeling extremely proud
extremely thankful and extremely blessed
that i was born in the greatest country
in the world
hey i guess i am an extremist
[Music]
all right it's a big flag
how about you angry blackmail
[Music]
that's dorothy
yes it was the fourth of july
yes we celebrate america's independence
yes this country was built
on the backs of men and women
of all colors creeds
to make it what we are today
so cheers to everybody
that's it
[Music]
so i hope you all had a good fourth but
now it's the sixth
you might want to take that flag down
now before you get reported
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest she's 50 class
50
staff and 50 bad at math townhall.com
editor fox news
if you can't laugh at his jokes just
look at his face
writer and comedian joe devito
she's like a rubber band thin useful but
bound to snap sooner or later
fox news contributor cat tip
and he's a big fish in every pond my
massive sidekick and host of an upset on
foxation tyrus
tyrus it's easy to laugh at those
students but don't they deserve to be
laughed at
uh no as a parent i would be crying
i'd be like this is what this is what my
college money you're coming home
today get in the van leave your stuff no
you don't need your books
you're not using them maybe some of
these congressmen who
in congress women who said the freedom's
not for us
but you work in the department in charge
of that
yeah so if you can't do your job
why are you there exactly what are you
doing miss waters yeah like it's undis
country's not free
your black woman sitting in office
elected by your peers of multiple colors
sexes genders etc that kind of means you
are yeah like it's just
what are we doing yeah it's true it's
true
so katie the thing okay so you see the
students
and you can kind of forgive them even
though it's kind of sad
but to tyrus's point these are people
that were elected there are leaders and
they
they are very honestly telling you how
they feel about america
maybe that's good that we know well
maybe it's good so we know exactly how
to
combat it right the problem is that
college campuses have basically spilled
over into real life we used to think
that hey you graduate from college you
get a real job you look at your paycheck
and all the taxes are coming out of it
and
you see the light of smaller government
and wanting to just be left alone
that's not the case anymore and if you
look at where that was taken i mean
georgetown is like the whitest
campus yeah it's always like the white
chicks
who are like i'm so embarrassed about
america
oh my god it's so bad but i don't want
to go anywhere else because that's gross
can you talk more like that
i feel a new character coming on
it is true though where does that come
from and also the up talk
did you notice tuck yeah it's like and
so you know it's racist
and embarrassing it's embarrassing i
really need a latte
so yes i'm going to yoga now bye
yes so joe i when i was uh
it used to be it was cool in the old
days to be patriotic
and it was scary to be anti-patriotic it
has flipped in order to enter all the
cool clubs
you got on this country yeah well the
only encouraging thing from watching
those students is that they
they've been indoctrinated but they
clearly have not been paying attention
in any of their classes
so uh yeah it's weird well they go right
to racism and all that because that's
their move you know
they say if all you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail although
no one shown there is going to be doing
any kind of manual labor definitely
none of that i think the colleges should
be required to teach a class in
patriotism that would be fun to see the
faculty's head spin around because
there's
hardly any colleges united states that
don't take some money from the
government
right so if we're going to be giving
them taxpayers money why don't we make
them teach
a little bit of gratitude and it would
be nice if that actually worked its way
up to
some of our esteemed congresspersons
there i i don't know what this problem
is in the west
where we're the only culture that is so
dedicated to denigrating ourselves
you don't hear estonians don't have
problems with their
their people on their olympic teams
turning the backs of their flags
they don't have that problem in hungary
they don't have that problem with people
coming from kenya but somehow in the
united states
you can receive all of these things and
still be mad as hell and yeah
it shows a real lack of gratitude and an
unrealistic view of the world because
yeah no one in the history of this
planet has had it easier than an
american college student yeah and
the scary thing about it is we can no
longer believe that they will grow out
of it
because we're looking at 50 and 60 year
old people with this mentality
who are in office seven-year-old people
that have are in office
i want a cat i really want to talk about
the hydrofoil
zuckerberg but i realized that maybe you
didn't do your research on the hydrofoil
so i mean i what research is there to do
what's that the most amazing video you
ever saw i watched the video
yes that's the research oh great job cat
[Laughter]
oh yeah don't encourage her thank you uh
no obviously it's the least relatable
thing i've ever seen
like ever i don't even know what that
was i'm not even at the level of money
where i know what that was
yeah um but we'll get there uh i i
wanted to point out something quickly
about the fireworks article or
this is why the wokeness stuff makes no
sense because i don't think it makes
sense to
the people who are actually writing it
sometimes because obviously wokeness is
what they're going for fireworks are
racist you know they
disproportionately impact communities of
color but then if you like reading the
whole article
one of the solutions they suggested was
to
have police crack down on fireworks
and i'm like hang on yeah so your woke
solution is you want these
cops who you said uh you've been saying
for a year are all racists
yes to go into these communities of
color and go after these people for fun
do you how can you hold all these things
in your head at once
that is a great point thank you
excellent work hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else